all right your names
are Brandon and
Lewis you are BJ's Sons you are
Larry's grandsons Larry's grandsons
Larry Whitaker's
grandsons you guys are how old I'm 19
I'm 21 1921 you grew up here yeah where
where did you grow up exactly um over B
which is a couple Towns over right yeah
well no actually right here oh you grew
up in this house I grew up my buy R me
oh is that right yeah oh this Betty cuz
your mom's name is Betty as well yeah so
Betty Whitaker raised you yeah she
raised me from like a 3 months old till
I was about six or seven why what was
your mom up to uh she was in uh North
Carolina why did she leave you guys hly
how how D you I stay I stayed down in
North Carolina until I was about 2: so
you guys were separated for a while yeah
and then she brought me back up here and
I stayed with my
grandpa that's why I'm so close with
him was was it like growing
up no dad bar you seen my mom when I did
she was either getting beat
on so beat on by your dad yeah stad
stepped in
yeah you guys like living here
now bad
should have like to get
away I plan on getting away soon where
would you like to go um I'm pushing for
Indiana right now some place that has a
more opportunity yeah what what what
kind of jobs are there for guys like you
well right now I'm working two jobs I
work at UH Hardies and then I just I got
a management job at Pizza Hut last
week so I'm doing that for now
and what are you doing Brandon I ain't
got a job right now I'm getting ready to
start back to work doing a underground
Bel line main is that a CO mine yeah you
you have kids uh yeah I got two and
another one on the way you do yeah I got
a little boy and a little girl we're not
sure what the other one is yet okay and
you have kids no
kids not right now keep it that way for
a
while what's it like growing up
here drugs are everywhere yeah I mean it
was pretty fun as a kid I
guess uh until you got older and then
like you kind of understand what was
going on but I remember sitting right
there I was like four and just sat there
and played in the gravel with cars dump
trucks my Betty and all of them they'
sit on the porch with their coffees and
watch us don't even recognize what that
house looks like now it used to look
very
different 5 10 years ago I still
remember when that tornado come through
I was right there where my grandpa's
front my truck is I was sitting on my uh
my bicycle and I looked right back
through there and I just seen a big
funnel you saw it spinning yeah I seen
it spinning I ran inside and told my
grandpa he didn't B me at first until he
walked outside and seen it and it shot
it was going back behind the mountain
and then knocked that tree down the line
at Betty's house right here yeah it was
it was actually in the back a big tree
in the back tree and it just fell right
in the middle of the house and uh oh I
remember that tree that fell yeah this
was it wasn't that long ago no it wasn't
long ago it was when that big storm
happened Ray Ray was pointing to it
trying to tell me something but I didn't
know what he was telling me well rain
and Timmy the tree just it fell right on
their room and it collapsed their their
room and they was laying in bed so wow
they it was they got
lucky how far how far did you guys go in
school uh I made it till 11th
grade made it till 11
yeah were there things you wanted to do
with your life other than work at
Hardies yeah what do you want to do uh I
wanted to be big time nurse doctor type
stuff you still can you're a young man
yeah I still can I plan on it just maybe
Indiana's the the
ticket
ticket pretty exciting but growing up as
a kid it got prettyy rough around like 5
or six cuz we went to foster care when I
was 6 I spent my seventh birthday in
there and then we got when we got out we
didn't come back up here we wasn't
allowed to see our grandpa in North
Carolina you went to foster care no up
here to foster care cuz of something
that happened up
here my grandpa tried to shoot one of
her one of our
stepdads he was in there he in there
Larry did this yeah he went there with
his little handgun good for Larry at the
wall scared him
away nice to know Larry can be be tough
when he needs to
be he can seem nice but he can be mean
yeah I like
Larry to death you uh you guys get
involved in
drugs I smok a little bit of we but
other than that I ain't never Ted
like hard hard like my mom yeah I just
smoke
weed I'm scared of everything
else but it's all around you all your
friends yeah it's everywhere it's
everywh you turn
here Bally every up here my mom she's
always been on she started out doing
pills and then progressed over year M ha
when and crack now yeah that's that's
how it goes
powerful I remember uh I remember when
we got out out of uh foster care we
moved to Helen it was uh it was all good
uh we was both on the football team on
the
Mountaineers and uh everything seemed to
all until like two years after that then
that's like when you could actually
catch on to it and see what they're
doing and then we moved the
Rodell and then that's when you could
really tell because then she started
losing weight a little bit and then proc
we we went down to Amigo I I I stayed in
Amigo with them for like four or 5 years
and then she like she just stopped
caring so just I was basically by
myself I left her house all that when I
was like 10 drugs are such a huge part
of the of this life down here how how
many of your friends are clean from
drugs drugs or not
using I don't I don't I don't talk to
people that much I don't got very much
friends cuz I I don't I don't see myself
as a likeable
person you that's it Brandon what did
you want to do with your
life well I'm basically doing what I
want to do I want to go to the co mines
ever since I was little boy yeah sh I
always been a grand mine this this used
to be coal mining country huh yeah you
guys you guys have both be coal miners
whether you liked it or not yes my older
brother he's he's a coal miner he's been
doing it for about 7 and 1/2 years he
works
underground trying to keep the family
Legacy going mhm there still got some
still some mindes active right yeah
those all kinds of Act of Ms around
they're opening more are they
yeah they they're progress more and more
every day putting in high wall Ms deep
mountains you guys have any regrets in
your life yes I do actually what's your
biggest regret uh getting locked up for
what uh just something I should have
told the truth about but I didn't I just
took
it took it for other people what were
you accused of oh I got charged when I
was uh 15 I got charged with first
deegree arson in
conspiracy and then when I was
16 they wanted to try us both as adults
but they knocked it down to a
misdemeanor and then I was on 18 months
probation about 6 months into the
probation I failed
it uh and then they took me back to
court for it I got locked up I think it
was like 7 7 and 1/2 months and then I I
got out I got out got a job and then I
wasn't out but like 4 4 and 1 half 5
months and then I went right back
and second time was the worst for me
because I actually it was locked down in
a Cell
24/7 all I did was stare at the
wall just really messed up my ha I got I
got to come out and shower and stuff
that was about it does that follow you
now at this point of your life no I
turned 18 it left my record okay that's
a good
thing what's it like growing up out here
in terms of like you know your age
now what kind of girls are there to to
date there ain't no girls around here no
no why not
uh just not they've all left town or
they're all in drugs or they're all what
they're just all money hunger that's all
he like is
money I mean you can probably find the
right girl in the
world I'm I'm going just stick with the
girl I got right now you got a
girlfriend now yeah that's
okay and and so you grew up with the
Whitakers yeah what was it like when you
were young yeah she is it was pretty
good actually couldn't ask for a a
better child you lived in that house
yeah there's no room in that house oh
yeah I know I used to sleep on a cuz
Freddy was Freddy was around then chair
right there where Betty Freddy and
Barbara were around yeah yeah they was
around there actually used to be another
bedroom right there where Betty's TV is
behind all that stuff there was another
bedroom and that's where I used to sleep
out when I was little I used to stay
right here with my grandpa all the time
and when them cars would come down here
and mess
around I won't lie to you I did I went
outside I I throw rocks at them people
like coming by to harass the
Whitakers
bot throw
eggs and i' I'd bring out potatoes eggs
I'll pick up Rock sticks and I throw it
just throw it at them one night I was
over here and uh I had a
firecracker and I grabbed something that
come out of a car and it was metal and I
stuck it in there and I lit it and they
were parked right there about where your
car is at but in the road and they were
sitting there blowing their horn and I
just threw it right just went through it
right through the windshield and went
boom they took off
D they get treated very differently now
yeah I I hated doing that I hated
messing people's stuff up but I also
hated people coming up here messing with
them yeah all they get is love now it's
really pretty
nice
I took them out yesterday and day before
and they just get like everywhere they
go people like oh my God I want to take
a photo with you I can't wait to see the
video I want to see excited Ray W yeah
Ray Ray enjoyed boiling
[Music]
yeah what's the hardest part of living
down here La lack of
opportunity yeah less opportunities you
get
depressing a
lot I cuz I mean that every day you got
to think if you're going to pull through
or not and make it to the end of the day
and then eventually what happens to some
people is is the weekend comes around
and drugs are being offered and yeah
that's what I'm scared of every
day I don't want to see myself doing
that I see my mom doing it too much and
it's just something I don't want it
to so you have how many kids Brandon two
two and one on the way yeah and what do
you think of the prospects of them
growing up out here honestly I I don't
know I I worry about it
it's one of my biggest worries I don't I
don't I honestly I don't think I'm going
stick around here too much
longer but I'm I'm working on getting a
place as soon as I can get enough saved
up and I'll probably get away from
here yeah see ain't nothing here for me
really except for them only reason I'm
still around once anything happens my
and Betty and them I gone from this
place I won't be around here no more
that's the only thing keeping me around
here what was your favorite memory with
the Whitakers sh that's a lot of them
see I don't think I honestly have a
favorite one
out one name one just I mean honestly
probably has to be with Freddy we used
to fish and stuff around here all the
time he' always have a can of worms in a
fishing pole every week and we come up
here he'd want to go right down here
behind the chicken pin and go
fishing I miss that sometime yeah Freddy
was nice yeah he he looked like Ray but
he was mellow yeah he was a lot Cal
right until you really push his you
really push if if Betty went out and you
you told him that she wasn't getting no
chicken he he'd go he'd go house that
that was his favorite part about every
month got Fried Chicken but Ray used to
be nuts yeah Ray was nuts he was nuts he
used to run off all the time and
everything he actually got lost for like
three days Ray did Ray got lost for
three days ended up down there in
Amiga he just went for a long walk yeah
where did he walk he was walking up the
holl or he from EJ EJ up here all up all
the way for how many days 3 days just
walking through the night yeah he
walking through I don't honestly I don't
know how he made it I don't either it
was crazy and then uh I remember when we
was up here and uh he got he got bit by
a copperhead up there yeah he walked
down the road like down the holler he
come down here got a shovel walked back
up there and killed snake brought the he
brought down it was alive on the shovel
when he brought it down here and
show talking about he he
kept point to his hand sh and he
survived a copperhead bite yeah they let
him keep the snake for five or six days
they they let him keep the snake they
killed it and put it in a little tube
for and he kept it for the longest time
I don't know what happened to
it that's a great
story all right Brandon Lewis thank you
so much for sharing your thoughts and
stories I wish you guys lots of luck
with whatever you do good luck in
Indiana if you go man thank you all
right thanks you guys thank
you